tenemos aquí una ecuación de matrices
tenemos por aquí una matriz a que está
multiplicando a esta matriz nada una
matriz b por esta otra matriz más una
matriz c por esto y resulta que esta
suma es igual a esta matriz de dos por
dos ok esto es un acertijo y además
tenemos una pista que es que cada una de
estas matrices abc o es una matriz
identidad
o es una matriz cero
ok como las que acabamos de ver bueno
entonces veamos yo creo que lo más fácil
es ir entrada por entrada así es que
como le vamos a hacer para obtener por
aquí un número dos a ver estas matrices
abc pueden ser o la matriz identidad o
la matriz 0 si alguna de estas fuera la
matriz identidad entonces cuando hacemos
la multiplicación de estas dos matrices
lo que nos queda es simplemente esta
matriz y por otro lado si una de estas
matrices es la matriz 0 pues lo que nos
queda de esta multiplicación es
simplemente otra matriz 0 que pues a la
hora de sumar las entradas pues vamos a
estar sumando 0 entonces es como si
desapareciera esta matriz de la ecuación
entonces pues como tenemos aquí un 2
sabemos que queremos sumar únicamente
dos de estas matrices así es que dos
matrices van a ser la matriz identidad y
otra de esas matrices va a ser la matriz
cero que podría ser una de esas
identidades y entonces tendríamos que
sumar ésta
entrada y se podría ser otra de esas
matrices identidades y entonces
estaríamos sumando esta entrada y pues
nos queda uno más uno dos y bueno eso
nos podría hacer creer que las matrices
que tienen que ser la identidad son las
matrices b y c y la matriz a tiene que
ser cero sin embargo si ponemos que cese
a la matriz cero esta matriz desaparece
de la ecuación y la matriz a es la
matriz identidad entonces también
tenemos que sumar esta entrada y también
nos queda 1 más 1 igualados así es que
todavía no tenemos suficiente
información como para saber cuáles son
las matrices identidad y cuáles son los
matrices 0 ahora todavía tenemos otras
tres entradas que nos pueden dar
información entonces vamos a ver qué nos
dice esta entrada
ok cómo le vamos a hacer para que la
suma de estas matrices tenga un 4 en
esta entrada a ver vamos a ver
pongamos que la matriz a y la matriz b
son matrices identidad y la matriz ce es
una matriz 0 entonces después tenemos la
identidad por esta matriz nos queda
simplemente esta matriz luego la
identidad por esta matriz y nos queda
simplemente esta matriz y finalmente un
0 por esta matriz así es que esto se
convierte en una matriz de puros ceros y
entonces cuando sumamos estas entradas
para poder obtener esta entrada nos
queda tres menos cinco menos dos que es
distinto de cuatro cierto entonces estas
dos matrices a y b no pueden ser la
matriz identidad y c la matriz 0 así es
que tenemos que tratar con otro a ver
vamos a ver qué tal que la matriz de y
la matriz se son las matrices identidad
y la matriz a es la matriz 0 entonces
esta multiplicación se convierte en la
matriz 0 y para obtener esta entrada
tenemos que sumar
esta entrada con esta entrada y nos
queda menos 4 pero pues el menos 4
tampoco es igual al 4 así es que este
escenario tampoco nos sirve y ahora si
el único escenario que nos queda es
cuando esta es la matriz identidad está
también esa identidad y esta es la
matriz 0 entonces hay que checar si eso
sí hace que estas entradas sumen esto y
pues si no 3 más 14 bueno entonces
parece que estamos cerca parece ser que
éstas tienen que ser la matriz identidad
y está la matriz 0 pero pues tenemos que
verificar este resultado entonces a ver
estamos diciendo que la matriz a la
matriz identidad y que la matriz c es la
matriz identidad y que la matriz b es la
matriz
0000 entonces veamos a ver si tenemos la
matriz identidad y la multiplicamos por
esta matriz nos queda la matriz 1 3 4 -
luego tenemos que sumarle una matriz que
es pura ceros por otra matriz que
termina siendo la matriz de puros ceros
de tamaño 2 por 2 que si se la sumamos a
esta matriz pues nos queda simplemente
esta matriz entonces vamos por aquí
tenemos la matriz identidad por esta
matriz que nos queda simplemente esta
matriz que
11 32
y si hacemos esta suma nos queda 1 1 2 3
1 4437 y menos dos más dos es un 0 así
es que si es igual a la matriz a la que
queríamos que fuera igual entonces a ese
tiene que ser la matriz identidad y b
tiene que ser la matriz 0